this is my blackened salmon shrimp with
the lemon butter sauce and it's so good
let's go first things first I like to
square off my fillet chop off the top
trim the belly keep those for something
else and Portion them into six ounce
fillets next you want to oil them up use
whatever you got or the vegetable canola
up to you season with salt garlic powder
smoked paprika and lemon pepper exact
measurements will be on the screen from
there give it a nice mix and get the
back side as well in a large pan over a
medium high heat we're going to saute
the salmon presentation side down first
for about five minutes once you have a
nice color give it a flip after that
we're gonna add some butter we're gonna
baste for a few minutes add some big dog
shrimp in my freezer still so again
we're going to season with the following
spices on the screen give it a mix we're
gonna saute it just for about two
minutes shrimp cooks really fast give it
a flip and from there let's plate up
folks this was absolutely amazing you
definitely gotta try it out